so you're still maintaining 2020  election was stolen is are we still  going with that listen i believe that  donald trump won the 2020 election i  believe that he won the election  you can't say that without saying that  there was a gigantic conspiracy across  this country and supervisor of elections  offices everywhere right to make this  happen and we haven't still seen any  evidence that proves that yeah because  so many of the courts that should have  taken those matters up rejected  evidentiary hearings on jurisdiction  grounds i mean i know the affidavits  that came out of michigan regarding the  tcf center in detroit now remember this  brings us back to  affidavits are not evidence and yes  affidavits affidavits can can be  introduced and examined but affidavits  are not actually evidence and this is  just another one of the lines that they  keep repeating it's almost taking me  back to december of 2020. but we have  affidavi affidavits are not strictly  speaking evidence